Yeah, totally holding in a fart right now.
I don't remember what you look like.
I am pretending to be busy but I am literally Instagram stalking you.
Hi, you don't edit your photos.
You do.
Doing my job.
Oh, um, ordering something that makes me sound feminine yet strong.
Um, ordering something I memorized years ago to make a good first impression.
Callback to a conversation we had online.
Oh, quick comment to let you know I'm on board.
Standard question about your life.
Generic answer, trying to hide my crazy.
A thing that worked with other guys.
Things that worked with other girls.
Oh, a thing that worked with other guys.
Thing that some girls actually like.
Controversial joke to test the waters.
Negative reaction.
Shutting this down.
Being nice to the waitstaff.
Not noted.
Awkward silence.